[Musique]
pourquoi je sais je sais je suis couvert
de taches de couleurs ce n'est pas une
maladie et je n'ai pas traversé un arc
en ciel dont non c'est une histoire de
boîtes de peinture
et puisque vous insistez je vais vous la
raconter l'autre jour les petites
étaient en train d'apprendre leurs
leçons
[Musique]
pourquoi nous fêtons à prendre les
affluents du dos nu au cas où on se
promènerait embarque dessus tu doives
offrant un jour la version danube
ça m'étonnerait le maire donne lecture
bonjour madame henderson
la personne bonjour bonjour et ds êtes
vous bien sa vie qu'elle ferait pas trop
j'espère au mieux l'excellent tous les
trains défaut bonjour fouet bonjour je
n'ai pas vous que je viens voir
je crois que c'est l'anniversaire de
marine est aujourd'hui je lui ai apporté
de boîtes de peinture pour la
récompenser la récompenser pour son
anniversaire
y'a pas grand mérite à ça si je voudrais
bien avoir son âge et j'ai aussi apporté
une boîte de peinture à delphine en quel
honneur pour la faire patienter jusqu'à
ce dernier voulait gâté beaucoup trop
alfred mais c'est que j'aime les enfants
on voit bien que vous n'en avez pas là
vous pouvez remercier votre oncle lui
rend bien si c'est déjà fait regardez
comme elle s'en contente allez en voir
les petites descendu dans mon jeune âge
j'ai descendu dans mon jardin
quinze jours du romarin gentil
coquelicot mais tu as ressenti comme
l'écho nouveau gens n'avaient pas
accueilli trois bras j'en avais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il atteint jeudi dans son joli latin
tous les garçons de bain alors un gentil
coquelicot est un mot gentil coquelicot
nouveau de ce que c'est que cette
chanson petits sortent encore merci
l'angle alfred mais les stupides c'est
la maîtresse qui nous l'a apprise ferait
mieux de vous apprendre les affluent du
danube laisser aussi les avions un luxe
en avant bien rangé ses boîtes de
peinture on pourra s'en servir demain
non non non non non non demain pendant
que votre mère et moi nous serons aux
gens ou kaïré des haricots dans le
jardin et vous irez coupé du trèfle pour
les la peur comment mesurer nos boîtes
de peinture
on verra est ce que je fais de la
peinture moi ça on n'est pas fou nous
partons chant et vous vous rappelez ce
que je vous ai dit des haricots et du
trèfle et pas de mode de peinture sert à
rien d'avoir des choses qui ont toutes
façons survie si les gens n'avaient que
ce qui leur sert y en a une oreille à
ribéry nous on aurait tout fait ce qu'il
y a les petites
oui ça n'a pas l'air d'aller notre oncle
alfred nous a offert des boîtes de
peinture mais nos parents veulent que
nous cueillons bien haricots et que nous
confions dutraive l'enjeu de faire des
tableaux voilà départ ont bien coupable
on y lisait tout votre génie vous seriez
peut-être devenus de grands peintres
ne vous inquiétez pas à les peindre
tranquillement moi j'irai cueillir les
haricots et le cochon coupera le trèfle
il est très gentil mais ne mangeait pas
de la licorne du trèfle je déteste et
haricots secs mais moins jeu des fesses
de l'herbe cru vous avez encore
réveillés en sursaut
je fais mon travail et moi je ne
travaille pas peut-être me mets sucrés
marche avant vous et mais robin vous
avez tout de suite finie on a bien
raison de dire grand or et bête mais
taisez vous rabe aurions brimborions et
si je joue pas petit les faits si vous
voulez vous bien vous taire si vous vous
réconcilier nous ferons tout pour
atteindre ce but et bien moi aussi
il nous faut aussitôt été possible sur
les baux de grattouiller créé couleur
sans danger et les couleurs avec danger
sûrement j'ai souvent entendu diop
prenez garde à la peinture il paraît que
vous allez faire de la peinture
pourriez-vous faire mon portrait nous
les bêtes au madère l'occasion de se
voir tel courbet s'est entendu nous
frottons portrait pourriez-vous faire le
mien aussi
c'est pas possible tu es blanc couleur
que le papier tv réponse jauzion blanc
c'est pas comme si je n'existais pas
fait main et bien si je n'existe pas
[Musique]
nulle part puisque je n'existe pas ne
faites pas attention il est susceptible
comme à cheval
pensez plutôt à faire beau portrait
[Musique]
ne pousse pas sur tout ça doit être bien
agréable de faire mon portrait ce n'est
pas que je veuille me plaquer mais mes
plumes ont vraiment des couleurs
adorable il convient aux bestioles
d'être ainsi bariolés ça leur permet de
ne pas passer inaperçu tétouan valton
portrait maman faire celui de la halle
je peux voir non pas tout de suite
nous organisons une exposition bon jour
là comment veux tu peux te fang 2 avec
profil
je crois que je suis plus gros de
profils sites palaiseau
à propos des oreilles je voudrais te
dire
elles sont longues c'est entendu mais tu
sais quel bord oui oui oui je n'ai su ce
qu'il faut alors vous avez exposé mon
portrait oui dans la cour comme nous
rentrerons
[Musique]
j'espère qu'ils vont être conteur
difficile oh eh bien les petites sommes
vraiment beaucoup de talent a battu m'a
l'air plus gros que moi c'est que je
dois être plus gros que tout je ne
pensais pas avoir les oreilles sont
longues on ne se connaît jamais bien
haut et mais pas trop quoi fait pas qu
il y ait des velléités alors les devants
tôt le coq est ravi bah je pense qu il
est plus gros que moi quand on est loin
on paraît plus petit qu quand on est
prêt
alors il fallait me peindre de tout près
si je t'avais pain de près une soirée
pas entrer dans ma famille et moi on le
voit que mes oreilles et encore ce n'est
pas le plus grave
mais je les plus que 2 4 mais malgré des
avis nous n'avons que faire
les explications scientifiques je
constate que je n'ai que deux pattes et
moi que je suis plus petit que le coq et
moi que je n'existe pas qui est 10 1 e
mois
le beau ce plan je suis de tout coeur
avec vous
jamais les orties
[Musique]
ans
alors j'ai pensé aux haricots et autres
f1 pour y penser on ya pensé jusque vous
avez bien travaillé cet après midi vous
pourrez certes elle a battu la sagesse
est toujours récompensé je suis tout
même est tombé je suis toujours étonné
quand vous ne faites pas de sottises et
attrayante pour aller chercher des
semences de pomme de terre au village
bien nous allons au village je regrette
mais je n'ai plus que deux pattes pour
vous servir
qu'est ce que tu chantes la wii 2 pattes
même que j'ai bien du mal à me tenir
debout ou tu sais pas comment vous
faites les gens de la fièvre
tu es resté dans les courants d'air
par exemple
beth qui avait encore ses quatre pattes
ce matin
[Musique]
lève-toi cheval
nous partons pour le village mais je
suis levé patrons commencent à lever ou
es-tu alors je suis là mais s'il s'agit
de maquiller à la voiture je vous
préviens que je suis tout petit je n'y
comprends plus rien je suis mignon n'est
ce pas un vrai cheval d'appartement ne
comptez pas non plus sur moi
qu est ce qu a parlé là le boeuf blanc
mais où es tu nul pas je n'existe plus
[Musique]
qu'avez-vous fait ce matin très haricots
qu'est-ce que tu là je viens de l'écurie
lane n'a plus que deux pattes
le cheval est grand comme un lapin quant
aux boeufs blanc il n'existe plus vous
direz ce que vous voudrez mais tout ça
n'est pas très normal
en effet c'est assez bizarre je vous
soupçonne d'y être pour quelque chose
ça l'est toujours si j'ai la preuve que
c'est votre faute
je pense que je ferais il faudrait
peut-être commencer par consulter le
vétérinaire vous êtes une idée je vais
aller le chercher
je vais aller avec votre père je te plus
en plus de rhumatismes vous voulez
consulter le vétérinaire non petite
saute le docteur et en attendant prenez
garde
ouah leboeuf blanc ou un bac blanc
n'existe plus lexis de plus qui comprend
quelque chose
naturellement c'est clair comme le jour
je ne trouve pas les gens veulent
toujours ressemblé à l'idée qu'on se
fait d'eux les belles scènes sous
vétérinaire est très malin a sûrement
découvre un poteau rose
je les entends déjà dire je perds choix
dans tout ceci comme une malade et de
peinture
quelqu'un peut-il pas à feu de la
peinture ce matin
j'ai demandé aux animaux de faire un
effort vieille fille vin blanc et bois
si la wii cheval écoutez nous n'avons
pas voulu froisser
c'est bien triste de voir un homme si
grossier je tenais misérablement et un
cheval superbe et amber magnifique
réduit à suppose et non non rien du tout
non seulement on avait beaucoup de
chagrin
je dois en avoir aussi nous entêter donc
pas mener gentiment allait toutefois ma
vie qu'elle n'assistait pas j'ai deux
pattes g de pâte
il n'y a pas à y revenir mais moi je
n'existe pas et moi je suis tout petit
homme à sutton a fait pour moi et moi je
trouve que tout est pour le mieux mais
je crois pas avoir trop mis que je te
battrais les fesses il va je crois que
j'ai une idée nous manque a toujours des
bandits des ce que la peinture a fait la
peinture doit le défaire nous allons
peindre les balkans elles sont mêmes
plus bas lequel ne sont mais pour jeunes
s'ils voulaient copiera dans un livre
d'image je le passerai en blanc sur du
papier gris oui je suis assez
intelligent on va copier les bat là
dedans c'est un beau livre de prix on
les sort je n'ai pas forcément un livre
de prix les plus beaux tableaux du monde
irait bachata rien débat de porto
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils n'auront rien à nous reprocher
maintenant si et quand tu es maintenant
vous avez fait de gros progrès en pâture
les deux acquittements
évidemment ça me rendrait service mais
moi je ne détestait pas existé surtout à
cette saison leur bep tendre et le
cheval est aussi avec nous mais ils
n'arrivent pas jusqu'à la fenêtre
regardez le monde d'en haut c'était tout
de même bien agréable on ne sait pas on
vous en veut peut-être toujours ce doit
être dans notre inconscient aux parents
arrivent avec le vétérinaire
ils sont au bout de la route ils seront
là dans dix minutes
nous regrettons nous regrettons beaucoup
tu vas me la passer dans la tête moment
et en colère s'en prend toujours un
malin
c'est alors que j'ai décidé d'intervenir
j'avais compris comme vous l'avez
compris vous aussi pourquoi le cheval
reste est petit pourquoi lan n'avait que
deux pattes et pourquoi le boeuf
s'obstinait à ne pas vouloir exister
c'était une question d'orgueil et seul
l'amour ou l'amitié peut venir à bout de
l'orgueil
j'ai donc expliqué à ses trois imbéciles
de bêtes que les petites les aimais bien
que les avait toujours bien soigné
qu'elle allait être sévèrement punis et
cetera
bref je fis un discours si touchants et
si magnifique quel finir par céder car
il faut vous dire que toutes les bêtes
ont du coeur à part le tigre et encore
[Musique]
voyons un peu ce boeuf invisible ce
cheval lapin et s'étale à deux pattes
je ne comprends pas pourtant tout à
l'heure ouais je comprends très bien
c'est pas vétérinaire qu'il fallait
faire venir
c'est un médecin veut avoir des troubles
de la vue
tous assurent que non à à moins que vous
n'ayez abusé du petit vin du pays mais
non non pas et je vous pardonne de
m'avoir déranger pour rien vous avez la
juge hallée petite fille et on voit tout
de suite qu'ils sont sage et obéissante
et spa petit oui mais légal et renvoie
les entraves